[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy
hablaremos del derecho de los cubanos a
la libertad de expresión en todas sus
formas esto en el contexto de las
protestas sociales que estallaron el 11
de julio y que fueron catalogadas como
las mayores en décadas contra el
gobierno de la isla para ello saludo en
este momento a alejandro gonzález
periodista independiente y director
ejecutivo del observatorio cubano de
derechos humanos señor gonzález
bienvenido a france 24 en la
constitución cubana se prohíbe la
propiedad privada de los medios de
comunicación como se puede informar la
realidad de lo que ocurre en cuba con
medios parcializados y un internet
precario e incluso con cortes en el
servicio
es muy difícil y todo dentro de cuba de
lo referente a la a
la información como hemos visto en los
últimos días el gobierno cubano que
tiene la propiedad de todos los medios
de difusión que ha bloqueado la internet
que ha tenido un uso expansivo en los
últimos tiempos y que ha constituido se
ha constituido en una herramienta de la
sociedad civil y de la oposición
pacífica para distribuir la información
esto ha sido de uno
el instrumento que ha permitido esta
movilización el gobierno que sabe que
esto funciona de esta manera pues ha
dedicado tiempo y me digan los esfuerzos
en contener este flujo de información
con apagones en todo el país que poco a
poco se están restableciendo en cuba
el acceso a la información es es muy
precario porque el gobierno también que
tiene la capacidad de bloquear
diferentes sitios web que lo hace
con total discrecionalidad no el
gobierno cubano tiene la facultad de
permitirle al pueblo cubano lo que tiene
que leer lo que puede visitar nuestro
sitio web por ejemplo que es un sitio de
una institución que
y defiende y monitorea el tema de los
derechos humanos en cuba bueno
no se puede ver el tema de la libertad
de expresión es tremendo el problema de
cuba es que en la constitución ellos
haya anunciado ciertos derechos que
después en la práctica no son no se
traducen en un ejercicio activo de esos
derechos y entonces cuáles son las
consecuencias tanto para los periodistas
independientes que intentan hacer su
trabajo como para los cubanos en general
que no pueden acceder a información y
opiniones que difieren de la ideología
estatal
bueno los periodistas que luego el todo
aquel que el comunicador social el de
todo que se dedique a al tema de la
información corre el riesgo de ir a
prisión hemos visto en estos días
detener a un sinnúmero de personas que
estaban intentando informar sobre lo que
estaba sucediendo yo me refiero al caso
que más cerca me toca que es el caso de
henry constantin ferreiro que es un
joven gay camagüey que tiene un portal
digital que se llama a la hora de cuba
en la cual ellos es un medio alternativo
en el cual ellos su información
información que recopilan en las calles
de cuba y henri con trust in ferrer
ferreiro pero que tuvo en prisión desde
el día 11 hasta hace un par de días que
lo liberaron
naifeh rigau y otras otra periodista de
su medio esto es solamente un botón de
muestra de lo que sucede en cuba con el
periodismo independiente hay que decir
que este este grupo de jóvenes y este
henri konstantín en miembros de la
sociedad interamericana de prensa y con
todo y eso tiene digamos un paraguas de
protección otros y eso ha sido detenido
y encarcelado y está sujeto a juicio
señor gonzález brevemente es el gobierno
cubano trata de justificar las
restricciones y sus acciones señalando
los efectos negativos del embargo
estadounidense
este argumento puede considerarse
acertado en medio de la situación que
vive la isla
el argumento del bloqueo es un argumento
que el gobierno utilizado durante muchos
años para cubrirse sus ineficiencias y
sus carencias
por ejemplo yo voy a decir un ejemplo
que siempre digo vale que me pregunta el
bloqueo no tiene la culpa de que el 50
más del 50 por ciento de la tierra
cultivable en cuba esté cubierta de mala
hierba
el bloqueo no tiene la culpa de que los
campesinos en cuba no puedan producir
porque el estado lo que le paga es una
miseria y luego esa la mayoría de la
producción
se pierde en el campo sin que el estado
la recojan
señor gonzález pues a usted muchísimas
gracias por esta información por este
análisis que nos comparten france24 hoy
a ustedes gracias por su sintonía
continúen con nosotros que hay más aquí
en france 24
[Música]